deslizándose hacia las vacaciones muchas
estaciones de esquí en france se han
abierto para la temporada pero bajo una
larga lista de reglas para prevenir el
cob y ahora se requiere de un pase
sanitario para acceder a la pista y el
uso de tapabocas en el teleférico pero
muchos esquiadores lo consideran una
simple formalidad previa a tocar la
nieve tenemos que adaptarnos no tenemos
elección si queremos seguir adelante así
es sencillo una vez hecho está listo y
podemos disfrutar un vídeo el año pasado
la industria del esquí en francia cerró
en parte al brote de coronavirus lo cual
generó miles de millones en pérdidas
para el sector y requirió un paquete de
ayudas del gobierno por 5 mil 400
millones de euros este año hay alegría
por las re aperturas las reservas están
aumentando por lo menos un 80 por ciento
en alpe d'huez hay esperanza pero
también hay inquietud
como sabemos que en cualquier momento
todo podría detenerse estamos seguros o
relativamente creemos que seguramente
habrá menos extranjeros pero esperamos
que haya más franceses que pasen sus
vacaciones aquí sé que quizás deba
consejos para aquellos que sueñan con
ver el sol al otro lado del mundo viajar
al extranjero se está volviendo cada vez
más complicado por el miedo a la
variante o micro es por eso que los
cambios en las restricciones de viaje
han llevado a muchos a abandonar su idea
de viajar lejos
nos quedamos en francia ir al extranjero
no es opción para este año tenemos
cuidado es
complicado al extranjero
pero lo que podrían ser pérdidas para la
aviación podría representar ganancias
para los trenes la reserva de boletos
dentro de francia ha aumentado con unos
3 millones de boletos vendidos para
estas vacaciones una cifra superior a
los niveles previos al cob y otro
ganador son los alquileres vacacionales
donde alrededor del 80% de las casas de
arriendo temporal en francia se han
agotado para año nuevo